I want to point out that all of the
world's evil comes to
egalitarianism whenever you have a woman
that says we need to fight for this
relationship equally um there's two
places she went wrong number one once a
guy is to the point that women select
him meaning he has his Fitness in check
he has his money in check he has his
game in check you know it takes met a
lot of work to get to the point to be a
guy that we want to marry and really I
would argue that women should put more
effort into the relationship than men I
think it works better that way men have
to focus on God on their purpose and
women are supposed to submit to the
authority of the man in their life